I don't have to prove anything right
because I know there's not another
vehicle on that road that can beat me
[Music]
I'm Matt see Andrea and this is car
collectors my name is Jeff Dunham
and I am a comedian and a controllable
we're sitting right now in my private
warehouse in Los Angeles drive them
around as much as I can they don't just
sit here there's a romance into me a car
is a piece of artwork man yeah yeah
thanks I came away and seeing the toys
thanks for inviting me over I know you
have such a great car collection I've
been dying to see this for a while tell
me about this Humvee well it's actually
not a Humvee to Hummer
because the whole uh military ones yeah
that's the technical difference it's a
DuPont chrome illusion paint the
flip-flop paint so this particular one
goes from blue to purple the red to
orange depending on the sound the light
I promised my accountant that if I
bought this thing I would drive it for
ten years and never buy another vehicle
and I drove this thing for ten years
this is my daily driver yeah a freaking
Batmobile not a Batmobile the Batmobile
was a stand-in car was actually used in
the film I've seen a lot of prop cars
and there's no way it came this way
this car was made to drive 300 feet
twice it's a plywood fiberglass prop
we've kept everything completely uh as
it was in the film as as we should have
but on the inside we made it drivable
and we put an ls7 engine in a Corvette
engine in it we changed the suspension
put air-conditioning in it actually got
it street-legal we have four cameras on
it so you have no blind spots there's
actually a license plate that dropped
down electronically all right so can you
open it up well you do it just like in
the movie Batmobile open
I don't think it's squeaked like that in
the movie hi baby
I see you've got a Morgan background
what's unique about this car built by
hand by like I guess like 30 guys in
England we picked the paint we picked
the leather whatever you want they will
put in this car I only have two
non-american cars this one and Clara
let's go check it out all right
Jeff I absolutely love this car the
McLaren is one of my favorite modern
cars tell me about why did you get this
car on this McLaren my favorite thing
about it is how to open the door okay
is it like that will do we need to say
open I wish so it's it's unlocked it's
raised I'm like I don't know click down
here yeah there's no clue how to open it
I'll give you a hint you're not gonna
feel anything right there's nobody
there's nothing under there something I
think it's unbelievably cool you just
take your hand right here and slide it
like that opens this door that opens the
door go ahead okay key you try it right
just slide it along the bottom I don't
think there's a there's a quicker car in
this entire collection Jeff I love the
Ford GT
you must as well because you have to
yeah exactly maybe you just may
completely different me or maybe just
couldn't figure out what color you
wanted this is the GT and this is the GT
x1 and the GTX one was the gen all D
group they got ahold of the handful of
these blessed by Ford and they turned
them into the GTX 1 which they they chop
the top off the car normally is what
about 550 horsepower is 800 at the
flywheel come here it oh yeah sure I
gotta sit into here all right let's do
it
hit the red button it sounds amazing
but I like it when the roof cut off oh
yeah the roof cut off is great yeah I'm
driving the either one of them this is a
lot more fun the other one's a little
bit claustrophobic this is this is way
nice the Plymouth CUDA a beautiful
vehicle alright so this is a what your
it's a 70 numbers-matching but it is a
beautiful vehicle I mean it's that's
that's what american muscle's all about
and I love the color combination this is
called the fender tag over here okay and
then the fender tag is stamped encode
everything that this vehicle is right
everything from what stereo is in there
to what color the seats are to what size
the engine is all the little details
would go through the assembly line the
guys would look at the code they would
install whatever's on the code the screw
would get painted over and then the last
inspector would come by inspect the car
he would then take the last screw and
put it in by hand all right well thanks
yeah
little details that no one cares about
Jeff thank you so much what an amazing
car clutch you'll be clearing your 4 GTS
your muscle cars I dig your Morgan I
don't appreciate you guys coming by this
has been a lot of fun so we'll do it
again sometime
for more great car collectors videos
subscribe to GQ calm
[Music]